you know first of all I want to bring up
the fact that you and Jack have known
each other for a long time you've
performed together doing improv many
times
oh yeah hundreds of times and we were
talking about Jax
you know southern accent and he would
give you a hard time about your accent
on stage yeah when I when I started
going to New York
to do comedy I was driving in from New
Jersey where I grew up and I lived in
Jersey my whole life I went to Rutgers
University where everybody's from Jersey
so I didn't even know I had an accent
like I thought everybody sounded like
Carmela soprano I just thought that was
happen sure I would say horrible and
terrible and awesome and coffee and if
they're the only person like I was
pretty brutally mocked for my accent by
Jack McBrayer yes yes
so mr. nice guy not so nice huh I've
never met anybody from New Jersey
yeah horrible terrible it was confusing
and endearing yeah and here we are today
everybody picks on him so much that he
needed somebody to pick on yeah it
rolled downhill on to me yeah well
that's the behavior of a true bully
anyway
you